vamos a resolver este problema dice las
regulaciones requieren que las etiquetas
en los envases de alimentos disponibles
para la venta al público indiquen con
precisión la cantidad de productos en
esos envases específicamente si en las
etiquetas de los envases de la leche se
mencionan que contienen 128 onzas
líquidas y la media del número de onzas
líquidas de leche en los envases es de
al menos 128 se considera que el
procesador de leche cumple con las
regulaciones requeridas las máquinas de
llenado pueden ajustarse a la cantidad
necesaria para la etiqueta la
variabilidad en el proceso de llenado
causa que el contenido actual de los
envases de leche tenga una distribución
normal en la línea de procesamiento de
una planta se tomó una muestra aleatoria
de 12 envases de leche y se registró la
cantidad de leche en cada envase
después nos dicen la media muestral y la
desviación estándar de esa muestra de
dos envases fue de 127 punto 2 y 2.1
onzas líquidas respectivamente existe
evidencia suficiente para concluir que
la planta de empaquetado de leche no
cumple con las regulaciones requeridas
justifican estadísticamente tu respuesta
pausa el vídeo e intenta resolver este
inciso
bien vamos a trabajarlo juntos primero
vamos a definir
como la cantidad media de leche en la
población de envases en la planta qué es
lo que nos importa con ésta mundo
podemos definir nuestras hipótesis
nuestra hipótesis nolan será que estamos
conformes podemos decir que la media de
la población de los envases es de 128
onzas líquidas esta es la cantidad
mínima que necesitamos para estar
conformes ahora nuestra hipótesis
alternativa será que estamos inconformes
podemos decir que mundo la media de la
población de envases es menor que 128
onzas líquidas esta es la situación
donde estamos inconformes estamos
inconformes en la hipótesis alternativa
si vamos a hacer una prueba de
significancia necesitamos establecer un
nivel de significancia así que vamos a
hacerlo si no te has enterado lo que
intento hacer en este vídeo es lo que se
espera que hagas en un examen de hecho
esta es una pregunta del examen ap de
estadística así que elijamos un nivel de
significancia de 0.05 porque este valor
es bastante típico y como no nos da
ninguno es importante establecer uno
antes de empezar
después queremos verificar nuestras
condiciones para la inferencia y esto
nos ayudará a sentirnos con la confianza
de que la muestra que estamos usando
para hacer la inferencia para realizar
nuestra prueba de significancia es una
muestra razonable la primera es la
condición de aleatoriedad
la necesitamos bueno nos dicen aquí que
tenemos una muestra aleatoria de 12
envases de leche si estuviéramos en el
examen ap
deberíamos escribirlo deberíamos decir
en el texto del problema nos dicen una
muestra aleatoria de dos envases de
leche
por lo tanto se cumple esta condición
ahora la segunda condición que nos
interesa es la condición de normalidad
ésta nos da la confianza de que nuestra
distribución muestral es aproximadamente
una normal ahora hay un par de formas
para saber si la cumplimos la primera es
que el tamaño de la muestra sea mayor o
igual a 30 si es así podemos decir que
nuestra distribución muestral es
aproximadamente normal pero en este caso
el tamaño de la muestra n es menor que
30 pero ahora pensemos en la segunda
forma para cumplir esta condición de
normalidad y es que los datos
originarios de los que se extrajo la
muestra se distribuyan de manera normal
y eso también nos lo dicen la
variabilidad en el proceso de llenado me
causa que el contenido actual de los
envases de leche tengan una distribución
normal
por lo tanto podemos escribirlo en el
texto del problema nos dicen el
contenido actual de los envases de leche
tiene una distribución normal por lo
tanto se cumple también esta condición
y la última condición que debemos
cumplir es la condición de independencia
esto nos da la confianza de que las
observaciones individuales de nuestra
muestra se puedan considerar
aproximadamente independientes la
primera forma de cumplirla es que
tomemos una muestra con reemplazo pero
este no es el caso parece que ellos
tomaron los dos envases al mismo tiempo
la segunda forma de cumplir esta
condición es que la muestra sea menor
que el 10% de la población total y por
lo tanto podemos decir bien la muestra
es aproximadamente independiente y esto
pasa así que lo vamos a escribir no
tenemos una muestra con reemplazo
si suponemos que 12 es menor que el 10%
entonces se cumple esta condición
por lo tanto parece que cumplimos las
tres condiciones necesarias para la
inferencia y por lo tanto podemos
suponer que se cumplen ya que no nos dan
información que indique lo contrario y
ahora lo que haremos será calcular el
estadístico tema y cuando el calcular
nuestro valor pero para compararlo con
nuestro nivel de significancia y de todo
esto ver qué conclusiones podemos
obtener y si en cualquier momento te
sientes inspirado y no es resuelto el
problema pausa el vídeo e inténtalo por
lo tanto nuestro estadístico tema será
igual a la media muestral menos la media
que suponemos en la hipótesis nula y es
más déjame introducir la anotación
correspondiente este subíndice cero se
refiere a la media que suponemos en la
hipótesis nula ok y todo esto lo
dividiremos entre
idealmente si estuviéramos trabajando
con un estadístico z entonces diríamos
entre la desviación estándar de la
distribución nuestra al de las medias a
lo que suele llamarse el error estándar
de la media
ahora la razón por la que estoy
trabajando con un estadístico tema es
porque no sabemos cuánto vale la
desviación estándar de la distribución
muestral de las medias pero podemos
estimar la usando la desviación estándar
de la muestra dividida entre la raíz
cuadrada del tamaño de la muestra una
vez más siempre es bueno que si estás
trabajando en tu examen expliques o en
calma cada una de estas cosas si usas
una anotación estándar las personas
suelen suponer a qué te refieres pero si
tienes tiempo en tu examen te recomiendo
que expliques un poco más lo que
representan estas variables ok en este
caso vamos a tener bueno primero tengo
la media de la muestra que como dice acá
arriba 127.2 menos ya esto le voy a
quitar la media que suponemos en la
hipótesis nula lo cual es la 128 y esto
lo voy a dividir entre la desviación
estándar de la muestra que acá arriba
dice que fue
2.1 y eso lo voy a dividir entre la raíz
cuadrada de 12 y usemos nuestra
calculadora para ver que obtenemos de
respuesta tengo 127.2 menos 128 todo
esto dividido entre 2.1 que a su vez
está dividido entre la raíz cuadrada de
12 ok esto va a ser igual am y tengo
menos 1.32 redondeamos entonces déjenme
escribirlo vamos a escribir que esto es
aproximadamente menos 1 punto 32 y ahora
podemos obtener nuestro valor p el cual
es la probabilidad de obtener un
estadístico tema así o más bajo es decir
tema menor o igual que menos 1.32
así que de nuevo voy a traer mi
calculadora y usaré la función de
distribución acumulada para el
estadístico t si nos vamos al menú de
distribuciones entonces voy a poner
segunda función este botón de aquí me
manda al menú de distribuciones y voy a
seleccionar la opción 6 vamos a usar la
función de distribución acumulada para t
y esta vez nos interesa lo que ocurre en
la cola izquierda es decir me interesa
el área bajo la curva de stem menos
infinito por lo tanto voy a tomar este
valor menos 1 por 10 a la 99 e iré hasta
e incluyendo el valor de menos 1 punto
32 después por acá abajo me piden los
grados de libertad
efe que recuerda son el tamaño de mi
muestra menos 1 el tamaño de mi muestra
es 12 menos 1 es 11 por lo tanto voy a
copiarla en mi menú de operaciones
observa lo que dice mi función es lo
siguiente voy a aplicar la función de
distribución acumulada para t es decir
la función de cdf desde bueno un valor
muy pequeño desde menos infinito hasta
menos 1.32 con 11 grados de libertad
todo esto debes anotarlo en tu examen es
importante porque así sabrán de dónde
obtuviste el resultado y bueno esto será
cero punto 107 por lo tanto déjame
escribirlo si bajamos un poco esta
pantalla esto es aproximadamente igual a
cero punto 107
y es importante mencionar cómo lo
calculamos así que escribiremos usamos
la función de distribución acumulada
para ti
es decir la función de cdf desde bueno
desde un valor muy pequeño desde menos
infinito hasta menos 1.32 con 11 grados
de libertad así obtuvimos este resultado
ok
tal vez sea bueno que grafique mos la
distribución t por aquí
esta será la media de la distribución
tema y ésta está acá es el área que nos
interesa
este cálculo representa esta área de
aquí y todo esto nos ayuda a que nos
entiendan al revisar nuestro examen y en
este momento ya es hora de hacer una
conclusión podemos comparar este
resultado con nuestro nivel de
significancia preestablecido
entonces escribiremos ya que 0.176 yorke
nuestro nivel de significancia es decir
es mayor que 0.5 que es alfa entonces
vamos en rechazar la hipótesis nula bien
leamos de nuevo la pregunta para
asegurarnos de que tenemos la respuesta
correcta existe evidencia suficiente
para concluir que la planta de
empaquetado de leche no cumple con las
regulaciones requeridas por lo tanto
otra forma de decir lo mismo es la
siguiente no existe evidencia suficiente
para concluir que la planta de
empaquetado no cumple con las
regulaciones requeridas
y ya está hemos acabado nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo